[Music]
we've got a problem
[Music]
I'm sorry I can't wear a man's cocaine
around here's the three of us friends
for life you guys think I'm like doing
the right thing I'm marrying Tracy hey
guys it's time to go I've been sitting
here a long time what would you do if
your best friend was about to make the
biggest mistake of his life everybody
makes a mistake huh
sometimes these mistakes there for
eternity stop the wedding I can't let
you do this I wanted to say this earlier
you know before your family got involved
and Jesus was here but but the point is
that she is not the one for him you said
it yourself I did not I did not say that
[Music]
hello drink I should be married and on
my honeymoon because of you and your
[ __ ] I am going to [ __ ] die here okay
where are you I went down the resort to
get raped be back I got carjacked man
those were my grandfather's tubs they
took that too
so you got carjacked and then you got
tuxedo jacked I am naked in the middle
of Mexico you sure yes I'm [ __ ] sure
there is naked we got to go find it
prepare now boys all we have to do is go
down to Mexico I'm out keep our heads on
a swivel and rescue Nardo
[Applause]
they're driving New Mexico and they
write back no extra stops not after this
one we're we going
look they spelled [ __ ] wrong right no
wait a minute are you taking my kidney
ma'am don't usually take it ease from
the back that's a doctor's to it we just
scoop everything out until we find the
kidney throw it in a cooler and we are
out of here you can't do this you can't
do this shut your fat face you dumb
dildo
I'm coming for you crazy Oh have you
that wrong yes nor no where are you now
I don't know everything's in [ __ ]
Mexican words something says [ __ ]
what get cat get cassette here good
cashier get cash here sorry